it hurts because it like it it damages
slightly my faith in humanity to be able
to see
um
the love that connects us and then to
see that I'm trying to find that
and that's I'm doing my best in the in
the limited capabilities I have to find
that and so to call me something uh like
a bad actor essentially from whatever
perspective it just makes me realize
well
um people don't have empathy and
compassion for each other it makes me
question that for a brief moment and
that that's like a crack and it hurts
how many people do this to your face
uh very few yeah so it's online e
muscles man they're just like I have to
be honest that uh it's it happens yeah
because I've hung around with uh with
Rogan enough
when your platform grows there's people
that will come up to Joe and say stuff
to his face
that they forget they they still
um they forget he's actually a real
human being
they'll they'll make accusations about
him so does that cause him to wall
himself off more no he's uh he's pretty
gangster on that but um yeah it still
hurts if you're if you're human if
you've really um
feel others I think that's also the
difference with with Joe and me
he has a
his family that he deeply loves and
that's an escape from the world for him
um there's a loneliness in me that's I'm
always longing to connect with people
and with like regular people and like
just to to learn their stories and so on
and so if you open yourself up that way
the things they tell you can really hurt